okay well four people joining this
livestream we are talking about a new
functionality for version 12
wolfin language to do with natural
language processing and text analysis
and hopefully um
let me just say this in the right place
we should have some interesting things
to see um
okay what's that there are some still to
solve okay all right so let's take a
look at text cases which is here
being asked to look for city country and
dates okay and give both the string and
the interpretation so how I was a bit
slow
is that the expected speed
shut up
oh is that startup stuff that was going
on there was that big
now that was a little faster is a
caching or is the startup identity like
put put a semicolon there is
interpretation also that takes I think
oh yeah the praetor took time also which
was van cache so we don't see it here
these interpreter caches yes we don't
know about that I believe that it does
for this purpose can can you check that
who's coming here by the way Sushma okay
it's Los Angeles twice pretty my bet is
a display is a display that was yeah
that was quite fast
it's quite nice it's quite nice so let's
say um and the state of LA
no Louisiana though so
say if I say New Orleans well you don't
have state here yeah city country date
oh really good point okay so if I do
that so I guess so you could add oh look
at that that was clever of it it knew
that
okay so let's remove la here and see
whether it does the right thing
oh very good I'm impressed except why
didn't that work
what is that I didn't cut it took all
this as a full string well that's wrong
oh that's to end indeed interpret okay
it could interpret NYC comma SF she gave
the strain because he could interpret it
how does it know it's a city well I
believe it was the city network
beleaguered City but it didn't verify it
it did then yeah you have to check
interpretation for that okay so if I now
to do this with a Czech interpretation
arrow true yeah yeah then it will only
return what is now a database I mean by
the way that that does seem to be some
auto-completion issues there and by the
way interpreters - that's what I thought
okay that was pretty cool
okay so let's look at this
that color for the snippet is a bit
garish I think we all agree these
highlights a string right or highlight
highlighted highlighted and if you can
make people change that that would be
great
well um sorry that that is the use of
highlighted in a string gives you this
it's a roll with strings and highlighted
strings
yeah it's a user highlighted right the
function I mean documentation I like it
it's all all you know so wait a second
so I'm sorry you're using highlighted I
lost it for a second they're using some
highlighted function with string it has
a background option you can change if
you don't want to change the default as
that takes longer I don't know what well
okay but but I like this eyelet
everything alighted and I do all stuff I
think and what I use here is a roll of
this stuff and normal strings yeah I I
think I mean highlight is probably right
for other purposes but um you know here
it really seems to I mean maybe you
should just use a different thing for
the snippet I mean and also it's not
obvious to me that you should do so how
are we doing snippet highlighting in in
text search it's the same I a took it
from there that's the point
actually I'm talking about the state
properties section after okay
all right okay which means omits a great
ordering know that under yeah so yeah
this is the texture sure acceptor where
you can ask us snippets and you've also
done that in
so in finding [ __ ] it was already there
and then now I have adopt about the name
because it was called related sentence
so now I added also snippet to friend
texture answer where is that this is
salia sentence or paragraph it's what's
that come before and after and if it's
the beginning of a sentence that it
takes just after so hold on a second so
snippet is not highlighted step it just
means give me where you got where you
thought you got the information from
actually it is elated in that case the
function snippet does not do a highlight
but take searched a call it's a snippet
property with eye light so I took it but
they also have a talked about this name
and snippet because there is not the
notion of highlights insider sorry I
keep on getting distracted here I
apologize the so when my right now we
support separate snippet and find
textual answer is that correct yeah I
know no it's correct yeah I did it two
at the same times to take statistics
contents and find takes your answer no
but you I did it just now right so is
not the previous version of Fanta to
answer didn't have stupid yeah exactly
is that the highlighted sentence and
paragraph which our almost listening
still things we can change
it's not okay so when they say
highlighted do they have highlights in
them or are they just those are that
that is the sentence that was at issue
did you understand my issue are you can
ask sentence or our highlighted sentence
and here on the screen we see related
sentence okay I I don't think snippets
should have highlighting by default okay
I think you should have to say
highlighted if you want you know I think
I think if you just want the sentence
you should just ask for sentence or ask
the paragraph doesn't make sense or or
ask for snippet which is a less defined
thing to get yeah we already have
contained
can ask fine cities you know and
containing like like the sentence
containing cities will really have a
thing for that so I don't think we need
some extra properties only the property
will be useful if they are some
highlight but I agree that it should be
highlighted snippet so I mean supplying
you know the containing thing is kind of
you know I don't think there's a problem
in supplying an alternate syntax where
you can say sentence or paragraph that's
what you want to get like here if we
really want to say you know fine texture
on so comma paragraph why not let them
do that well of course you have for fun
things aren't sorry to make more sense
for text cases no please we cannot
because we have to say okay sentence
containing what so we have to use
containing for text cases yeah but okay
what your my thing for saying is that
takes search currently as a snippet
right yeah and it's highlighted okay
that's a current design of text search
the first one that's probably wrong we
should probably revisit that for text
search okay it should probably become
highlighted template for text search is
anybody in this meeting representing
text search no okay well so can you take
that
that's probably Matt yeah I just don't
think this was an issue that was thought
about okay okay rename and should I keep
snippet without highlight as a property
or yes yes yes I think so snippet is
just the pure it doesn't make sense for
what doesn't make sense protects crisis
snippet why not because it's a bit of
what oh yes yes it's the output sorry
sorry sorry sorry
I thought it was like a forum sorry okay
I was wrong I think it should be well I
don't really know what it meant but it
means here either because I don't know
how big as a snippet
depends on actually it's taking more or
less 50 characters characters before and
after encoding not to create a world and
yeah if he's starting a sentence and
he's taking just the context after there
are these kind of heuristics to take
stuff around the hundred of characters
around your answer okay all right
seems okay and then highlighted snippet
is the highlighted version but how you
represent the highlighted version
whether it is a row or whether for
example we're burning that formatting
into a string is less clear to me we
already had this discussion for our
friend textual answer so I started with
a string okay and I convinced you to use
a row is that right yeah and after it
was seems to be ugly like if you asked
for the input from each listed yeah okay
fine so then we went to row so that's
what we should do for all of these
things so then highlighted star is a row
not a string should I suggest take
search people will also to use
highlighted stupid yes I think so
okay
so you the next points we're about text
contents okay so
you
interesting problem there I can't do the
selection because this is some totally
bizarre thing that got pasted in here
you want to give a road for dicks
contents no I don't well i'd yes
actually I would like to do that can I
do that no okay maybe we should let that
make that work but there's something
wrong with the selection here but maybe
we should make the road thing work so
that it's so they can eat its own output
so to speak get what I'm saying yeah
every independent text or independent or
should it concatenate us what should
concatenate a fee I think it should
concatenate yeah so well I know but it
should be able to eat its own output
okay that's an unfortunate one
probabilities for example it's not
grenade probability so what what do you
think I say it's also put probabilities
and positions but it cannot eat them
again but but at least eating
highlighted strange seems useful oh by
the way since Stephen is doing a no
probabilities we couldn't mention a new
option which is acceptance threshold so
you should be able to protect failfish
old 0.8 let's say and it should filter
okay exception to threshold also using
for image identify and so on yes yes we
updated everything old I mean the old
ribbon even threshold was renamed to
synchronize with this good okay and it's
being it's the documentation has been
updated most of it we are doing final
pass now which is the last week but it
will be if it's not it should be all
updated now and this is new by the way
in text cases because before we did and
this contents before we did what is this
what is this this is a this is an
unknown what is this so
the progress bars in our network when
when it's computing I mean to put a
progress bar because they have a
progress bar but I don't understand why
um that progress bar is the progress bar
I've never seen before it's an internal
progress bar on your network that now we
expose for text cases maybe we should do
something more ornate well yeah I mean
if it's internal but it's never been has
it is it seen by users or not yet I mean
ok so it just needs design ok so now
this is that kind of work that goes to
interpretation
ok ok so there's there's two things
obviously this is going read and it
shouldn't be right so that's probably
for you yeah and second of all it I
didn't autocomplete and an interesting
way for the right-hand side of that ok
okay what on earth is this doing this is
some kind of unban Terp rotational
presumably a problem yeah there's been
of timing once the net is done that you
still have to hunt down what's going on
exactly okay so okay so there's many
different problems here so one is an
interpretation problem as 19th century
should be correctly interpreted there
we're making sense and if it needs to be
interpreted as a computable date well I
think that should just interpret in the
pure date interpreter am I making sense
you know I understand but I mean I'm
saying the date interpreters should deal
with these cases yeah 1960s obviously is
a nice decade long you know thing if
we're making sense right we're gonna
find a lot of those with it because see
all networks cashy's many more things
that we can interpret yes I mean this is
good but this is some so for example if
I say here now I don't know whether what
this did is correct or whether it should
have said missing not interpret able for
those
it makes things pretty ugly yeah but I
mean what's the correct behavior of them
fail interpretation before we had the
failure object which was making things
look so bad like here you have like tens
of failure object a huge list yeah I
understand it but it's also gonna be
confusing if the thing you know I
suspect when we do experimental eyes
this function we should get rid of this
but probably for now now that it's well
it's still experimental we can let it
come out with there was a question we
wanted to know like we did experimental
eyes so 12 or we wait a bit more well we
should wait
given what it's doing here in other
words this should be set up so that
anything it should be the case that
anything that texts cases reports as a
date the date interpreter should eat in
the making sense this okay so babe
options check interpretation no no no I
I know that but but it would be good as
a just a matter of you know increasing
quality for dates yeah ill with this
yeah so okay that's for dates right
location for example does location get
interpreted it does not exist location
okay so what do I so it's only things
like City right okay so then City arrow
it's not gonna take forever
Atlantic doesn't strike me as a likely
city it's in Iowa it's very unlikely to
be the city in questions yes no I mean
stuff like that is is that how is it
feeding that is it just saying this
string is likely to be a city did you
understand what I'm saying and then it
feeds it to the to the city interpreter
exactly okay like it's kind of separated
which is important things there are not
entities and I think good right like
overly is clearly a city but not as
opposed to an airport
that strikes me as very unlikely to be a
city
strikes me as even more unlikely to be a
such a yes so okay so let's imagine that
I do this and I say acceptance threshold
can I do that yes
why doesn't it work
it's not available
dispersion is it only in the prototype
accident special no it should be here
maybe it's not documented in this
version but say you should put a 0.3 I
don't know no no you're right still
catches pink and no I don't think that's
right it's I think it's ignoring it I
you should maybe use the performance
goal goes to quality because maybe it's
using the spelling when you do this okay
so ignore the acceptance no network it
was using the Spelling's why the old
ones there because he hates the Russian
of last week sorry default should be
surely quality it is but you're looking
at last week's version I see okay fine
so that's okay so now what happened here
which works much better much better much
better this is much better
there's much better well done okay so
now what happens if we put an acceptance
special in here
we've got to do something about this
ridiculous thing I mean it's okay to
have a look it's better to have a a a
progress monitor than no progress
monitor but it will be even better they
will progress monitor the degrees
without our style guidelines that was
magnificent almost there so music live
stream if there's a scent a century
granularity for data objects there is so
there should be that when we say 19th
century here that should just work
in other words there is a date object
hum I think it would be you know 1800
and then we say granularity century
yep beautiful um
okay alright so let's keep going here
text contents hid in the doll - big
section that there interesting also for
Givenchy delaying the image content say
stuff first about the design of text
contents like which be the second and
third argument and also probably
properties and also about the types I
out to document all the types that we
can recognize with all these functions
okay
arguments so we should start with the
arguments we add team write about text
contents image contains kind of
consistency when why that was it in June
I think we kind of agreed but we didn't
discuss that much about the second and
third argument of X X contents which has
huge contents yeah and I think we mainly
agreed on the cases part so now image
cases is doing the same thing as tax
cases with like object goes to property
yeah so you can say dog goes to
probability or image similar to the city
goes to interpretation so that part has
been aligned but we yeah we're still not
perfectly aligned with with the contents
thing and also we are not I think we are
not even in the same on the same page
about how do we want to package this
contents thing so for that I said I
think we agreed last time yeah is it yes
but package I mean in the sense of
interface more than then result well so
in the case of image contents just like
image identify the category is second is
that correct
yes the point yeah that design was
copied from image identify them the
point here is that like we have these
cases function so shoddy and I were
thinking do we really need anything more
than the one argument form of the
contents function
these are discovery functions basically
well I think probably yeah I don't think
category belongs there I think
properties belong as you have it in text
contents I think you could do it the
same way around as text contents
properties comes first and types comes
comes you know properties comes second
types comes third if you're going to
give types
mm-my that is others is a problem to do
that is that is basically the same thing
as doing text cases with slightly
different syntax instead of an arrow now
you have two different arguments I think
it slightly confusing doing basically
the same thing well except that we want
to parameterize text contents because
text contents is going to return a data
set
whereas text cases does not only
difference is the one gives you target
basically output and the other one plain
all the difference is that there is a
approach a problem in the other
direction
one stuff to give you everything and you
restrict well the other one is you have
to obtain it's for everything you want
to I agree so I agree and then what's
the advantage of slicing in the function
and not in the data set because it might
be more efficient I don't really I'm not
really concerned you know I think if the
contents functions basically say well
this should basically say gives a data
set you know something
set of
and today's
identified in text gives the data set
about entities identified in text
something like that
make that change actually yeah then you
can review quickly the documentation to
do it I'm gonna run out of time here so
we need to be um then maybe we go to the
other point okay and let me go ahead and
update documentation so we're in a
position to do this um okay what was the
other point here
maybe it's in just before we switch one
reason why we had this order is so we
don't go back to this point again is
because you liked the idea to be able to
write image contents image comma dogs or
animals and I guess this was the
original suggestion for having the
category in the second argument which is
the same as image cases then exactly so
in this case it would be image contents
image comma image I guess the string to
get the sub image comma dog yeah I think
that's stupid I agree with what I agree
with my previous statement so the
difference here is the following in the
case of image contents there's a
hierarchy of things to look for that's
why that's useful because we can say
look for animals and you can have a
turtle and a peacock and other things in
the picture right whereas the analog
there isn't an analog of that to my
knowledge for text contents there are no
super categories for text contents are
there you just tried location that is in
a sense a super category it is although
the interpretation would give to your
positions yes it is a super category I
agree it didn't work so Jerome I mean I
think if you know text contents comma
location would work would be interesting
right that would be worthwhile
shoroma you with us yeah so I I so I'm
kind of getting convinced that text
contents should have the types second
with the expectation that most of the
time you would use the one argument form
if you do give the types it will be
super categories not the individual
things does that make sense
why not the individual things I guess
you can if you want to just a convenient
way but then it becomes very similar to
text cases except that it's defaulting
to giving you a data set right and then
the props should be some subset of all
the props that we think makes sense and
maybe by deposed yeah I mean by default
whatever yes but but but then you can
specify the ordering or which properties
to include all in automatic yes yes yeah
we reviewed the radio automatic we have
this whistling string concert position
probably snippet it's similar to what we
have for for images like you you went
through both of them so excellent okay
to be automatic and then all would be
everything of course yes excellent all
right let's keep going alright yeah
forget about that this one's just so
this is kind of a review of the four
type of stuff we would like to show
there's one type of turf that are
defined by by strings which is like
entity and the prototype grammatical
units you know like all the nouns and
stuff like that so city country date
person color nouns blah blah form all
what was kind of me starting a sentence
like do we want a non string way you
know that entity typed way to define
types because they could be conflict
with other strings so I think we can use
entity type can't we or does entity type
just return entity type could be much
more horrifying
so in my entity no we don't have we
don't have a I don't think we ever don't
have a wrapper that means that we have
the entity class so I think I think you
can do entity class city all
which can of would represent all the
cities but well that's a question for
the for the babies people I mean that's
a question we've just been going through
this issue of what that represents so I
think that will be a Carlow question
what what he thinks Carlo and Tony
question but this is very interesting I
mean this this type of thing yeah ok ok
so to continue the story so we have this
global types then we have specific
entities you can ask give me instance of
Apple entity in the text text level
semantic English pretty sentiment but
then do we want to say like if you want
to do let's say Arabic language entity
should it be interpreted as the text
level semantics like fine everything
that is in arabic language or as a
mention of the arabic language in the
text like she speaks arabic
no I understand
two different concepts the word Arabic
or a representation of the Arabic
language as opposed to something written
in the Arabic language so boy you know
it's it's like every philosophy question
is going to comes in becomes codes um
well clearly this should mean a
representation of the Arabic language
I hadn't really internalized the fact
you can look for entities here so for
example are you telling me that if I go
back up to our Toulouse example that if
I say here um
look for if I say control equals Paris
here
oh boy I had no idea and if I say Paris
arrow snippet or is it highlighted
snippet snippet
that's pretty cool if I might say so I
had no idea that worked so is it the
case that if I had you know NYC and
things like that but that would
similarly work so if I say texts cases
you
so it will go Oh Oh dad that's
disappointing it has to be in a sentence
because it's a neural network that it
should work in maybe put a performance
quality goes to true it's an old stuff
so let's we called instrumentation yeah
it's like an unfine wine I don't know
it's a week old that's not surprising
okay all right
well so check it out but that this
documented the fact that it can actually
take an entity yes what is it's a row in
the table in a big table of types but so
currently it doesn't have in this week
old version it doesn't have the right
spinnings
as a way that it does it first checks
over cities so I think they are grabbed
this it is no problem and then it checks
you know kind of a does it correspond to
one of our spinning fish which is you
interpreter I know it was his doing a
chain is normally it should we run the
network and then interpreter of all the
answers that's we are to city but yeah
that's then that must be these are this
wrong yeah Wow a new interpreter City no
that's not normal
it should grab it it should grab it
because interpreter City New York will
work right it work with v8s today it's
just a burger okay all right fine okay
all right let's keep going here um so I
think we've we've come to a conclusion
for what should happen here
we were down this okay
okay
look I think what we should do here is
name it instead of calling it English
boy
no I mean I guess that's okay to call it
English there because we're not you know
Arabic as a language has to be an entity
the the specific the singular Arabic is
an entity
the string oh boy
see okay so let's look at this so
language identify these returns entities
you
oh dear I'm surprised there isn't Latin
because we certainly have dictionaries
in Latin yeah it's just based on the
most valid the 16 must use long words
Wikipedia and Latin is not one of them
okay but there's Wikipedia lating should
be more used okay in any case it's a
minor bug who knows whether those words
exist in Slovenian
nice we'll grab that thing
whatever um okay so who knows what
happened there um okay
in any case doesn't really matter but
but my point is language identify is
returning that entity see sentiment
itself the sentiment identifier is
returning simply positive right and by
the way we probably should have we
should probably break out of classify
sentiment which probably should have a
sentiment classify or something function
because it's such a common thing yeah
and that way we could decorate it some
more but you know that's going to return
you know plus one or something has the
sentiment and how on earth do we
represent this I have to say that you
know what this really is is more
something where we're saying language is
English or some such other thing or
something like well I don't really know
what the sentiment is so here is a
suggestion okay is a suggestion what we
could do is to make this into an
association I mean this would get ornate
and maybe we can't support it all but
something like this
[Music]
right and that that will be the way to
represent I mean we can have some short
hands like this but that this is the
more general way to represent that yeah
so do we have
okay just no seizure no extra rapper
that's what I'm suggesting
no text I don't know text type or
something I don't think we need that I
mean I think for this purpose this will
be sufficient for this inauguration but
I think um I think it's I think this is
reasonably nice because this allows us
to do a combination of things which
would be and then if what we actually
have is um you know if also we have
whatever the generic name type city is
that the right right term or what what
do we call that
I mean thence really entity type what
what are we calling those things
we are we call them form or type in
documentation we prefer the type of
but something like a date is not an
entity type no but its type of stuff I
don't know not an entity type but well
so it could be that it could be form
arrow city I need for marrow date it
makes more sense for matter I'm not sure
they mix that well because only
sentiment language topic the paradigm is
give the long West's piece of string
that the satisfied is given sentiment or
that is given long given topic well what
about what about yes I understand that
but what about having a city inside a
positive sentiment thing how would we do
that
can we do that I guess I will be in you
know with containing yeah containing
positive sentiment so ever containing
okay so well okay so then what is this
that is containing actually could it
like containing sentence I remember the
order well it containing it will be
sentenced comma something another right
yeah City let's say and then you could
do a sentiment goes to I don't know how
I know we would want no no it doesn't
know it doesn't work we don't diversion
without well I mean we could imagine
making all of this into an association
like like extent arrow sentence and then
all these pieces here this
for the full form of stuff like this
okay I think perhaps for this version if
we have I mean how many topic names do
we have what topics do we have classify
it classify Facebook so it's a Facebook
topic at the moment okay but that's a
fairly specific set of topics and I mean
it's interesting but I think we're going
to have to decorate that because you
know we might have topics you know as
we've discussed finding a robust sort of
global topic list is really hard yes 25
classes in Facebook yeah
books carrier money social media family
and friends fashion fitness blah blah
blah blah's television transport travel
video games weather yeah I remember
roughly what those were I mean it's cool
it so it's an interesting list of topics
and it's great that we can do I mean the
fact that we don't have a topic
classification thing for you know a
single we don't have a function which
simple do we yeah we do we have Facebook
topic right but classify we can give a
Facebook topic we don't have yet took
the gun on if I just like because we
because we didn't feel you know a couple
years ago we looked at this we just
didn't feel we could generate a robust
global list of topics um yes we could
it's well it's really hard we went
through this I mean is it based on you
know there's academic topics there's
what you know academic field this paper
is in there's where would the book show
up in the Library of Congress there's
where would DMO Z classify it there's a
bunch of different kinds of
classifications and there really isn't a
global notion of this it really depends
what you want it for so I don't think
it's the right thing to happen it would
be a logical thing like an image on
safari I think I don't think well I you
know we looked at this and it looked
really hard to do this in a globally
useful way because there are attributes
of a text like something might be a
polemic
or you know a piece of political text
but it might be about you know the
problem of encroaching you know species
or something or it might be about
something different and then the
question is is the topic politics or is
the topic yeah ecology and so I think
it's a finer-grained issue but let's see
in terms of look we are gonna run out of
time unfortunately here um boy that's
good I think no this is his kind of the
details of what we already talked about
so what I was looking for yeah it was a
way to decrement all the possible types
because we have many all right and well
now I did like metaphor that if you if
you don't give any argument it returns
you something with the list I think
that's a total hack yeah but I yeah
that's a question of what function
possibility I mean I think what we
should do I mean first of all we just
needed in the straight documentation
pages okay where you say any entity
right it's any entity it's going to work
is that not correct
any entity any language any entity type
so you can we don't have the complete
list actually well why don't we consider
the ones that don't work - b-bugs - now
unless there's a good reason why they
can't work well can you characterize
which ones don't work I mean the
traitors the network was trained on a
subset of them
how many 180 okay and how did you pick
those ones the ones that were making
sense for me okay which was the ones
that didn't make sense can you
characterize what those were and why
they didn't make sense there were
several cases there was a case of food
where there was a lot of Commonwealth so
in this case it was more me that I could
not construct manage that the set with
the strategy I was using some doesn't
make sense right and some also what I
suggest we do is we say you know first
we need good error messages if you give
an entity that doesn't work okay that
makes sense
yep second thing what we need to do is
write a you know in the documentation we
need to basically say entities that make
sense work and not really describe what
those are here if you really insist on
having this one possibility is to put
this data set into the data repository
you are sure that all this will work
with this version normally but well I I
don't have a really great solution for
this I mean I think that um I understand
I mean you look you can leave this hack
in there for now okay until we have a
better solution for this okay last thing
if you go up a little bit more so it was
the last type okay it's aliases for
group types oh so it's kind of a spoof
thing we've been thinking of it is the
ROM that has been pushing to all this
is let's say I want all the power of
speech later look I'm sorry I can't go
on right now um I I apologize it's a
pity this meeting got started late um we
can reschedule this later um can we can
we get that tell me maybe I don't know
if we can get her in tomorrow um last
very last thing I don't think it is
quite over I think there's a little bit
more stuff to discuss I mean all right
try try asking this question what is a
group type exactly so let's say power of
speech right now you have to do the
least noun coma coma determiner in order
to have return in association with noun
and then the least of all the now that
has been cracker grabbed verb and
release of all the world interrupt you
all not like to do something like power
of speech result but how is how is that
correspond to other I don't understand I
mean in other cases you're not giving
back city arrow whatever you know oh yes
no you're right if you just ask city
it won't even ask in back if you have to
for at least like city country it will
even asking back okay fine so then
there's no problem with this then then
then for example location if you wanted
to you could give something which would
be a you know that's a super category
where you would give some collection of
things back I personally think that yeah
okay I would like to look at this again
okay okay it's gonna take another hour
um and have some questions our live
stream let's see what about text
contents working for custom entity
property hierarchies
yeah great the problem there is you need
natural language understanding we are
working on related things we're working
on this but not not an immediate thing
we're making what you have here
leverages our
many you know lots of work that we've
done on our you for these existing
categories
um okay and another question about
arbitrary image sets um and
ah yes that is something you can do with
text cases I mean with image cases all
right so to be continued thanks a lot
good start all right very nice stuff
Thanks